we were in a pub afterwards just in
Inked near Grantham and we were just
finishing off a calculation because we
wanted to show something relate the end
of the unit the end of the universe to a
dark energy as well dark energy is the
harbinger of this doom and some guys
with some pipes off and they were like
what clearly see is doing some
calculation or what are you doing we're
just showing that the universe is going
to add that they were like what it's
just that
we're going to start off talking about
something probably sixty symbols people
have heard about before what are we
going here and cause much of a constant
problem so I want to sort of explain
what it really is it's often sort of
understated or not explained properly in
you know well lots of places even within
scientific seminars well essentially you
think about the vacuum look at a vacuum
and you say right hasn't got any energy
you think well no it's a vacuum of
course not but actually that's not true
because quantum mechanically what you
find is is that little particles
essentially will pop in and out of
existence so you can think of them as
just popping in and our existence and
essentially you know for literally an
infinitesimal time and that that gives
the the vacuum and energy the question
is how much and it turns out it's an
awful lot if you use your standard
calculations to calculate how much this
is you find it's a huge amount of energy
in fact it's so much energy that it
would cause the universe to curve so
much that it wouldn't even extend as far
as the moon people have tried to come up
with models that sort of can suppress
the amount of a vacuum energy that you
get out and none of them been
particularly successful so then you sort
of face of the dilemma well how did the
universe how's the universe so big then
and and essentially what you say is is
okay I've just got a number a quantity
that can cancel off this vacuum energy
and it cancels it just cancels it off
very high ad hoc Matic manner to a huge
degree of accuracy and that you know
sort of this cancellation that allows
the universe to be to be much larger
it's a dimension full number the thing
that you throw in there is dumb it has
dimension hasn't dimension four
dimensions of mass essentially this is
an energy density itself so you're
thinking you throw in is an energy
density and so it's that energy density
you throw in just literally by hand that
you'd use to cancel off the energy
density of the vacuum and to try and
stop this this huge amount of curving of
the universe and what actually isn't
tiny though because when you explain to
me the vacuum energy you told me what
makes it you I know where it comes from
this it's particles popping in and out
of existence there's energy therefore
we've got this gravity these are all
things that
kind of sort of understand I don't
understand how just throwing this
cancellation number this density who is
that coming up well it see actually this
this happens all the time in in physics
and actually when as soon as you start
doing quantum mechanics you can ask what
the quantum Corrections are doing to
something and there for example the
charge of the electron right you can ask
what the quantum Corrections are to the
charge of the electron you get all these
infinities popping out and then you have
to add what we call it a counter term to
try and bring it back drag it back to
two finite values and so that this is a
bit like that it's like the counter term
that you have to add it seems like a
cop-out though like if I build my house
on a dodgy foundation and it started
leaning to the side
I couldn't just say okay number three
and everything's better I would have to
actually build stuff and fix things I
would have to physically do something to
fix the deficiency well I think that's a
very good point very bready is that this
is an excellent point of that it's
always cuts really to the true nature of
the problem the problem isn't really
that you do these consolations it's that
once you do the master be it you've done
that choice that you made should be
robust against any change in your your
description of nature if you like so so
if I just said that you need to
calculate the charge of the electron
you're canceling infinity so why are we
worrying with the cause much of constant
about cancelling huge numbers it's not
certainly no worse than cancelling
infinities so and that's where but the
point that it's generally missed about
the cosmo Jocasta form that's not really
the problem the true nature the
cosmological constant aalam is something
called radiative instability which is
this business where you know let's
suppose I calculate what the vacuum
energy is okay so what's my description
of nature well I take a description it's
valid down to the atomic scale and I get
one value for the vacuum energy and I
need to cancel that so I choose this
number to cancel up now I change by
description later I go down to to the
nuclear scale and I get a completely
different answer well and I need to do
the same cancellation to the same degree
of accuracy then I go down to the sub
nuclear scale and I get a different
answer again and I need to do the same
cancellation to the same degree of
accuracy and this is a completely
unstable process but surely there was
only one vacuum energy so
figure out which one you have to
calculate and use that stop calculating
it in different ways okay so like this
this really hits something quite deep
about about nature do we believe in
something called effective field things
that's that you can literally trust you
don't need to know all these details of
these the physics so if you're thinking
about stuff that say super nuclear
scales you don't need to worry about the
details below the sub nuclear scale so
for example do I you know Newton's
constant the law of gravity is that knew
the value of Newton's constant doesn't
change whether I decide to cut my
physics off at the atomic scale or the
nucleus scale or whatever right it stays
it stays pretty robust it's the same
value the problem of the cosmological
constant is as I'm changing that
description I'm having to keep retuning
this value this value that's really
applying on on the larger scales it
shouldn't need to worry about what's
going on it at the at the sub nuclear
scale and so on and as I move that
description once I made the choice it
should be robust and it really isn't so
whenever this happens in nature it
signals it has always signaled a lack of
understanding of what's going on we have
the same problem with the mass of the
Higgs incidentally it suffers from the
same kind of problem that it you know we
keep having to retune retune retune and
in that case supersymmetry solves it
case the cosmos are constant well it's a
different story
you know what what is going on like this
vacuum energy exists and has a quantity
is it measured or is it something that's
just modeled by people like you
mathematically look we don't know what
it actually what it's quantity is that
we just kind of coming up with models
and guessing what it is so okay good
question so the vacuum energy does
changes in the vacuum energy have been
measured now what do I mean by that
something called the Casimir effect
where the the value the vacuum entry is
sensitive to the boundary conditions of
your say I have two plates and um you
change the separation this cheat and you
can measure the change in the vacuum
energy as you as you change those
boundary conditions that's not really
the true vacuum energy ground state of
the universe it's not really what we're
just talking about sort of a localized
thing there
and so it really is all what you
actually measure is is that the
effective change in those boundary
conditions so in a sense the vacuum
energy the thing that gives you that is
also the same kind of thing that gives
you what we'll call the vacuum edge of
the universe the true ground state at
the universe so kind of yes but not
quite so then so now one asks so you
asked about being measuring this sort of
thing
so let's actually ask how do you measure
the cosmological constant okay how do
you measure the vacuum energy well the
true vacuum energy how do you measure it
can I measure it in this room to think I
can measure in this room well I don't
know probably not because of all that
noise from the construction yeah right
well you can't write heart rate so how
about you try and measure you might try
what are the features obvious it's
constant okay and as you go through
space it stays constant now I'm well I
can look for something that's behaving
constant in this room but I don't know
that when I open the door and go outside
that changes you just said it was
constant so what isn't the vacuum energy
in this room the same as it is of course
it is yes it absolutely is but but when
I find the thing that's something that's
constant is room how do I know that
that's the vacuum energy it could it
might not be because that it might stop
being constant when I go outside the
room or when I go outside the galaxy or
wherever right so or if I wait long
enough it might just change over time
but I just you know I have to wait long
enough to see it see it change well then
you weren't measuring the vacuum in it
absolutely you're not so then how do you
measure the vacuum energy can you
measure in a room clearly not because
you can't distinguish that scenario well
if it can't be distinguished then it can
never be measured well don't you have to
come up with a vacuum energy measuring
measuring device right okay so what so
what is that okay the only way to
measure the vacuum energy true vacuum
energy is to consider the entire
universe overall turn it's the only ways
the only way you can truly guarantee
that what you're talking about is
constant this nifty observation this is
this was due to you know like some
Nomura Connie Hamed Savas the muffler's
big guns of physics they made this
observation that you want to identify
the vacuum energy you have to scan all
of space and
time myself and a colleague of mine a
pneumonia we're we took what Nima and
services and friends had said and we
used it we said okay the only way if the
only way that you can measure the vacuum
energy is to take the whole of space and
time as one then the only way you can
properly cancel off our humanity is on
the same level so literally we're
demanding that this cancellation happens
over the whole universe that the
universe knows about a number it needs
to know okay and so we've managed to set
up dynamics which occurs over the whole
universe at once so what we've done is
we've we've got this number which is the
number that you use to counsel and we've
got another number which cannon knows
about the masses of particles and on the
level of the whole universe they talk to
each other and they do so so no matter
how you calculate the vacuum energy
whether you work at the atomic scale
whether you work at D whatever scale
those two will communicate in just the
right way that they'll cancel and so the
problem of this this issue we were
talking about just goes away this paper
you've written have you solved the
problem or have you just written down
how you don't worry everyone the
universe songs on its own so what we've
done is we've found a way to basically
deal with the polymers it was first
formulated that it's it's almost
criminally simple it doesn't require any
huge chain locally physics just looks
like you know Einstein's relativity
Einstein's general relativity there's no
change there why because we're changing
we don't we change Einstein's theory on
a global level as the universe as a
whole
right we don't play with it locally so
locally we get all the great predictions
of Einstein's theory but the change is
done as a whole because it had to be
done at that level now DM the funny
thing is because we're sort of assets of
describe we've got this way of getting
the the number that you need to cancel
this classical value of the cosmological
constant and the particle masses we get
them to communicate in a certain way
like I said on the universe as a whole
and what that means is it turns out that
the particle masses array are actually
related to the space-time volume of the
universe and in fact as you make the
space-time volume of the universe so
basically it's spatial size and how long
it exists for as you make that bigger as
a whole then the particle masses go down
and in fact if you had an infinite truly
infinite universe with existing for an
infinite amount of time and over an
infinite amount of space then that would
that would drive all the particle masses
to zero now we know just by looking
around us that the particle masses in
our universe are not zero so that
immediately tells us that if our model
is correct then actually the universe is
going to end we predict Armageddon it's
the main prediction of our of our theory
that the university never tably has to
end otherwise we wouldn't have a
universe with particle masses in and we
do so so the cancellation of the
cosmological constant is achieved
through it has this knock-on effect that
the universe has to be finite it would
predict that the universe grows from its
initial singularity grows out of it and
then it reaches a maximum size and then
drives into a Big Crunch and literally
at the Big Crunch time and space
completely ceases to exist so time only
exists for a finite finite length of
time and otherwise the particle masses
would have been zero this is if you
right if were is yes you do know the
mass of the particles in the universe
yes does that mean you know the number
attached to the cosmological constant
what number did you spit out okay so in
our Theory there there is a like a
residual leftover piece that you get so
the cancellation leaves a little bit
left over and then that is out that
number is smaller the bigger the
universe gets okay so that we're able to
show that it's less because the universe
is as big as it already is that it's
smaller than than some critical value
that doesn't screw up any any cosmology
is constantly ticking it's constantly
changing well it depends I mean it's
it's set it's a number it's fixed so the
universe is going to get as big as it's
gonna get it's not the change of your
time just that we know that you
is as big as it is now so this number
can't be any bigger than this particular
value and so you know the original
question God it's not bigger than the
dark energy don't steal which is what
and it's a midi electron volts to the
fourth so whatever that is
you want that you wouldn't want no this
is the smoking gun to make that I love
the exact numbers you know that it's not
well I mean we don't know how long the
universe is get a laugh alright so we
can't I can't possibly answer your
question I just know it's not bigger
than then the dark energy density